the church of what's happening now is
presented by on it
this show the church what's happening
now is proud to introduce you to
mybookie.net
there's a ton of bowl games this week
there's football still going on and
you're going to want to make a bet and
the best place to do it is at
mybookie.net and right now when you join
mybookie.net will match your first
deposit with a 100 bonus that's right if
you join with 100 you get a 200 banquo
to play with
visit my bookie
today or call 844 900 bets and use promo
code joey that's the most important part
promo code joey
go to mybookie.net today
the show is also brought to you by blue
apron
check out this week's menu and get your
first three meals for free with free
shipping by going to blueapron.com
church that's right with blue apron they
send all the fresh ingredients you need
to make incredible meals straight to
your door go to blue apron dot com slash
church right now to get your first three
meals for free
oh [ __ ]
kick that mule [ __ ]
kick it
kick that [ __ ] i want heaven to
hear that [ __ ] right there
the church of what's happening now
[ __ ]
christmas night
or the morning after the 26th
the phone
you look and see what the three meals
are okay okay
christmas [ __ ]
smile [ __ ]
merry christmas to everybody out there
thank you very much for tuning in to the
church of what's happening now
it's uncle joey diaz with my main little
[ __ ] jewish goomba elisa merry
christmas merry christmas to you what's
happening brother oh my gosh i had a
first of all i just want to say thank
you i had a great time in vegas and it
was uh you were very nice and you gave
me some like a gift card on a gift card
but you just want to go get a nice meal
and i one had a great steak so just i've
been thinking about it it made my whole
night like that night was my best night
of gambling i've ever had and you won
that night that was nice that was the
only night you won when you ate the
steak the next morning you woke up when
you kissed a dead self
and you [ __ ] lost my [ __ ] steak
money [ __ ] oh i don't it's uh
it was just so it was it was like the
perfect night i got a steak i got a nice
drink i could tell the other night that
you you're processing a lot the last
couple of weeks
i could tell when you do the edibles you
drift away and you've been a little
distant lately
so i could tell you needed two days but
i could also tell you
you needed a good meal you know to sit
down and
sometimes a good warm meal by yourself
even though sometimes they say it's
really unhealthy to eat by yourself
you know
when i'm when i go away on the weekends
sometimes
i i can't wait
because i eat by myself on saturday and
friday morning and
it just gives me you know it's like a
little breather
you're always surrounded by people you
know you always have people around your
family members your child your sister
your brother your cousin
and it's really nice to take care of
yourself
and you know lead
didn't do anything mind-boggling he went
the cheapest week you'd go to vegas you
want a cheap vacation
go to vegas christmas week oh it was the
best thing that's the cheapest thing you
could ever do in your life they give
they give the rooms away
they give the [ __ ] rooms away if you
ask them to like if you go you're not
going to count me i'm going to gamble
they'll give you for 25 bucks you get a
room on the strip yeah i got it for 45
on in mandalay bay which is a nice hotel
it's not like it's a quarter hotel or
anything i got a nice room they were
going to give me a suite for 15 bucks 15
more bucks a night 15 more bucks a night
yeah they'd give you a sweet they were
gonna give me bucks but i was by myself
so i just didn't want to walk around
like [ __ ] uh
no no but it was um i've never i never
really do that and it's
doing more specials for meals too
and little things like like i know you
go out there and shoot a [ __ ] sub
machine gun
were they giving you deals on that with
it
things like that because it's empty it's
empty correct it was empty this week
they said next week was going to be a
little bit busier like tomorrow morning
vegas backs up automatically tomorrow
morning the planes to miami back up
that's it those are new year's
destinations you know oh and i'm so glad
that i'm not i'll get this was the week
for all the people who are like me who
don't want to go to a club like as i was
leaving as i was driving out of vegas i
saw a billboard that said uh
it said like oh it's an open bar new
year's eve 25 bucks i was just like dad
that sounds like a nightmare that's a
headache
that's a [ __ ] headache that's a
hangover and a half or you could drink
on new year's and you're young
yeah you figure you get [ __ ] six
drinks
you're even and you want to polish those
first tricks drinks six drinks you're
probably even after one two drinks in
vegas it's over ten bucks a drink
oh yeah oh yeah it was
like it was i think i think the drink i
had at strip steak was close to 20 bucks
you had to drink the stupid would you
have makers and coke what i always get
look at you like a doctor so you got a
little drinking poo you got a little
steak
what else did you get oh and they give
you french fries for appetizers and i
forgot
i know lee loves french fries i [ __ ]
hate skinny french fries i [ __ ] hate
them in la every french fry has hiv
every french fry is skinnier than [ __ ]
i'm from the east coast where you get
steak fries all the time and this place
says but skirt steak has an appetizer to
give you french fries that are fried in
in duck fat and they give you three
different sauces next to it which i knew
would blow lee's [ __ ] mind every time
there's a ufc joe always takes us to
strip steak afterwards we meet at strip
steak and we just sit there the rest of
the [ __ ] night that's why i knew
about stripper snake not because i'm a
genius because you're taking it it's
[ __ ] delicious that place and those
fries
made my night because i
i don't whenever i go out to eat high i
i tend to giggle a little bit so i don't
i was like i don't want to go i don't
want to blow my cover
but i had to have something so i think
i'd like 600 milligrams
and they brought over this french fries
without even telling me
and it it was like heaven it was
there was one that had like you felt
behind the lottery you can't believe
they're bringing french fries most
people bring like [ __ ] noodles at a
chinese restaurant or bread or something
they open up a [ __ ] french fries and
they open up with with like it's not
like it's
sometimes when they give you something
for free it's like three little bites
this was
a huge order of french fry i put a
picture of it on my instagram it was a
huge order of french fries that was
there for my entire meal
it was uh
it was though the bartenders were great
and it's uh because i normally don't
like eating by myself
and i i think this night changed my
opinion because i've been i've lived
alone for a while and even now if like i
want to go eat i'll get take out and go
home and watch tv
just because i don't know i feel weird
being alone at a restaurant
but i i had a great time i had i was
talking to the bartenders i was what did
you say at the bar oh yeah yeah yeah i'm
gonna get a table yeah
you see that when i go on the road i go
to those places
and there's a line out the ass but the
bar is empty i just walk right in sit at
the [ __ ] bar i start talking to the
bartender there's three bartenders one
of them listens to some podcast
we're on at one point in our [ __ ]
lives we start talking about podcasting
or what am i doing in town or comedy and
it's kind of interesting you know
i hate going to restaurants
to towns and eating at a restaurant that
i could eat out anywhere oh yeah i want
to get a flavor of the town you know to
see what reflects on the town like when
i went to
portland with felicia we went to that
prime rib and chocolate cake and went to
another place these were all places from
that city that they had to offer when i
go to texas and you want to eat chinese
i'm like no go to chewie's i can only
get chewie's in austin or you could only
get this here you know i work myself up
so i'm happy that you ended up you want
to go to sushi i'm like you get sushi
here right trip steak you get here but
you got to go all the way into the heart
of beverly hills with [ __ ] traffic
and park it's a goddamn night man if
you're at the man and it's strip steak
is at the mandalay bay correct yeah it
couldn't be upstairs yeah it's right
it's right downstairs
but then like
and then i i like gambling but i'm not
good at like i i won't i won't spend
money on myself in other areas
like i used to go to vegas a couple
years ago and try to do this for a
couple days but i'd stay at like the
cheapest hotel on the strip i'd eat that
chipotle and then go back
and that's like that's not what vegas is
about and the vegas is like it has
vegas gets a bad rap but i i love it i
think it's great has the best
restaurants in the world
there's there are some negative aspects
to it but
the the amount of good food that you're
surrounded by is ama and then i found
this great deal online they gave me 100
bucks to use at the casino
at the resort so i got i had food i had
a bunch of meals for free they're lo
especially these weeks they're looking
to give you anything just to show up
it's pretty interesting
it's really nice you know i do listen
when i go on the road
i don't give a [ __ ] where i stay
i really don't
you know i was i slept on so many
couches and [ __ ]
a motel 6 works for me it really does
yeah you know as long as i have a hot
shower
and the cable works i'm pretty [ __ ]
good you know i i like security i don't
want [ __ ] crack hoes knocking on my
door for in the [ __ ] morning
but you know what i mean you know
but sometimes the club puts you
somewhere nice
and for two days you walk around you're
like you know what i'm a [ __ ] human
being you know for for two days
i'm gonna act i remember going to
riviera
and working the riviera had to be 20
years ago
and you know
i i was living on such a shoestring at
that time as a feature act
that everything is a break you know you
get no money when you're a feature act
so everything they everything every
break you could catch is like a [ __ ]
act of god it's like a miracle
and they used to give us a card i was
telling lee they used to give us a card
to eat in the employee cafeteria which
is the [ __ ] that gets sent back
from the buffet
like all the leftovers from all the
leftovers from buffets they got bite
marks in them and [ __ ] and
you know it's a nightmare you know
that's what you gotta eat
but when you're [ __ ] broke and you're
on the road that's who you gotta eat
so
when i would go on the road with joe it
was two different [ __ ] worlds like i
tell people all the time joe bought me
more steaks than my mother
when you go on the road with joe for the
ufc or something you stay at the best
hotel
and you know he doesn't give a [ __ ]
about steaks or whatever the [ __ ] you
get whatever you want on the menu you
like a doctor that's why when i started
hanging out with joe i i started
learning that you have to take care of
yourself
when the situation arises you know from
time to time just and it helps it gives
you another three months to you know it
just charges your batteries man let me
ask you this let's say you're in vegas
right and
you could stay at
i don't know
a motel 6 which would be fine or you
could stay at the mirage where the show
is let's just say
would this show be better if you were at
the mirage yeah comfortable hotel yeah
yeah [ __ ] yeah no listen you want the
least amount of movement
people think when i come to a town that
they're like they send me these
suggestions for food and they send me
suggestions to do
and i appreciate it from the bottom of
my heart
but i'm at an age right now and a point
in my life in my career and then when i
go on the road it's to relax so i want
the least movement as possible
i'm not going to go out to dinner before
a show
and burn myself out talking
when i could
just relax before the show yeah i needed
to look at so many little [ __ ] things
that you need to do to take care of you
you know i don't know who what guest was
on maybe about a year ago
and we discussed what does it take to be
you
it was very interesting what does it
take to be you there was a time where it
took a shower and a box of cereal and
[ __ ] a can of soda
to be me
you know and now comes a time where you
have to actually get up drink coffee
write a little bit
smoke a little bit
write a little bit you know eat
breakfast drink a pro drink a protein
shake take my blood pressure medication
i gotta rub cream on my [ __ ] rashes i
gotta rub baking soda on my fungi nail
what does it take to be you you know
like what does it take you know
you realize that in those moments when
you're taking care of yourself when
you're taking better care of yourself
you know when you have an option to
drink between a soda and there's a big
glass of water
there's those little things you know 10
years ago i would have just gone for the
soda at whatever time it was and drank
the whole bottle of [ __ ] soda you
know now
you're gonna go to sleep you have to
drink some [ __ ] water even though
you're gonna get up and pee in the
middle of night that's just
such a big difference when you take care
of you
you know and for years i never did
was it even a was it a conscious
decision because for me it was more just
like i got into a rhythm and then i got
so busy that you just don't think to
change your rhythm like when you get so
busy focusing on other things
like you just don't know all right this
is working i guess so i'll leave that
alone but then it's really not working i
got into a bad rhythm when i moved to
los angeles uh-huh yeah 99 when i moved
to los angeles in 99 is when my when my
health went kaput
but there's two reasons to that
and let's be frank and honest about them
the number one reason was my dedication
to comedy
that i put everything i had into comedy
my first
seven years here
but i could have put more into comedy if
i would have taken care of myself i
neglected myself
so for all those years i didn't care
what i ate i ate late at night
the mirror i looked at showed me in high
school
uh
it didn't show me as i was becoming 350
[ __ ] pounds you don't see that you
take a really
good good look which we don't really do
a lot of us don't see ourselves or don't
really want to look i didn't really want
to look
i just thought my clothes were getting
tighter because they were shrinking my
wife was shrinking the [ __ ] clothes
instead of going no i'm putting on
weight after weight after weight after
weight after weight
and then as soon as sleep apnea
developed
you know all these things contributed to
the sleep apnea and that took it to that
final level
of my health getting really shitty what
was my health getting really shitty i
had no energy
i was my diet was [ __ ] atrocious
there was no fruit there was no lettuce
there was 10 cans of soda a day
it was just plain abuse because
with the abuse i was doing with the
drugs who cares about everything else
i'm already doing drugs there's no
reason to be a hypocrite go to the gym
and try to lie to myself i was one of
those guys
really yeah i'm already in deep what's
the [ __ ] the gym gonna do for me
i'm doing an eight ball of [ __ ] coke
in two nights
and drinking this and eating this and
smoking this and smoking two packs of
cigarettes
what's the [ __ ] gym gonna do for me
nothing
that's how i looked at it from a stupid
perspective and today i pay for that
when i go to jiu jitsu and i gotta not
eat a donut with you or whatever i pay
for that you know
i pay for that
that time because we pay for everything
in our lives
the conscious decision
was when i stopped doing coke
then i said what did i do with myself
what did i do with my body what did i do
to my image
look at my clothes
my clothes were a day above [ __ ] uh
you know
i couldn't even fit in the rig oh i was
so fat that i was destroying my clothes
so i was just living in warm-ups
uh
i was doing that with you yeah
you live in [ __ ] warm-ups you know
that's the only way you're comfortable
you're not comfortable in pants anymore
once you get to a certain way you're not
comfortable at all i'm bad and you don't
want to buy new pants because you're
like oh i'm not getting yeah i'm going
to lose the weight so
but the conscious decision was probably
after i stopped getting high 208 i
finally went to weight watchers and i
started looking at different things and
i started going online
i always knew about proteins and diets
and lifting
i didn't i never incorporated rest into
that equation and that's a big part of
the equation you could eat great and
work out and gain weight because you're
not sleeping correctly
there's so many [ __ ] aspects
to our diet guys like you and me there's
so many aspects to our diet the number
one is sleep and number two
as soon as we get up we gotta eat
something to kick off
the thing and
for the rest of our day to be good
because guys like you and i will have a
donut for breakfast and not think about
it but that ruins your breakfast
or not eat breakfast and then you eat at
12
and now you gotta eat that fourth meal
you know or that fifth meal because you
didn't eat breakfast
there's so many different things that i
force myself to do i'm not hungry when i
wake up
i'm not hungry at all i look at my
daughter and i look at my wife arguing
with mercy and i know mercy's not hungry
she's my daughter she's not hungry i'm
not hungry in the morning if you left it
up to me i could get up at six and not
eat till ten
and that's not good for you right yeah
that's what i was you gotta eat like 30
minutes an hour after you get up you
know but i always drink a glass of cold
water to get my metabolism going which
again i didn't know until a couple of
years ago that you do how do you handle
the sleep thing because that's always
been an issue force yourself do you
sleep dude how often do you take naps
today i took two [ __ ] naps because
i'm looking at that old man well that's
not every day though no
no
uh
i never took a [ __ ] nap
until 1995.
okay i never i stopped napping when i
was about four
gave him a hard time at school all those
years gave my mother a hard time i never
napped do i start dating this girl in
seattle in 1995. she would take naps
every afternoon
and that forced me to nap
and that
is a big lifesaver a power nap from here
you know an hour and a half nap a 45
minute nap a two hour nap those are all
power savers but
even
as of lately as of six months ago
i was putting on a little bit of weight
and it was because i was getting home at
11 from the store
or from work or from comedy or something
like that
i would write for an hour
and then to detox from the writing i
would stay up till two watching tv like
all the [ __ ] you tell me to watch and
people tell me to tape i'd tape and
watch it till two
three and then i'd be lurking at seven
with mercy
by ten i can't keep my eyes open oh yeah
that's why it ruins my [ __ ] day i was
ruining my own days that's the issue
i've been having recently and i've
always had this issue and i like to stay
up late
and then it just when you wake up at
seven eight o'clock
the last
seven weeks i've been turning the tv off
at 12
11 30
11 30 i go in the room where's your
phone
outside really that's the move i think
because that's the issue my tv is not
even on most of the time it's the phone
the phone's in the other room in my
office i don't even see the phone when
i'm at home
unless if i go into that room i charge
it in there
there's a house phone in my bedroom in
case something happens in the middle of
night we're stuck in the bedroom
but my cell phone is far away from me
there's nights i leave it in the [ __ ]
car
overnight
you leaving the car what do i give a
[ __ ]
the people that are gonna call me aren't
gonna call me at night anybody who calls
me at three in the mornings for
something [ __ ] stupid anyway
it's not gonna be cause
nobody calls me at three no more that's
worth the [ __ ] ari calls me at two
sometimes
i'll see the call late night or early
morning or something
but nobody calls me in the middle of a
[ __ ] night so
nobody really calls after seven
for me to write i can't have the phone
by me
not even near you no
so once i write the phone goes into
another [ __ ] room charged up
that's why i leave the phone out so when
i walk in the house in the morning
i'd look at the phone and i plug it in
and i leave it in the kitchen and i go
in the office and write
when i take mercy to school i don't take
the phone
my wife's got a [ __ ] phone
then when i get home at 9 30 10 the
phone's there
i go to jiu jitsu i put the phone in the
[ __ ] god that phone ain't gonna get
picked up
jesus i i think that's a move i think
that's i don't have the phone near me at
all i don't want to look at social media
there's nothing for me to look at social
media for do you get distracted in hotel
rooms or do you keep it away from your
hotel rooms too yeah keep it away from
me and hotel rooms too
wow i put it in a pocket i'll put it in
my luggage and close the luggage
that's yeah that's what you have to do
now because otherwise if not you can't
write you're a zombie i can't write
i can't write
you have to turn off all can you know
for me to be effective in that area and
for me
once i get to the part where i have to
start making the calls in the morning
then i'll go in the other room and pull
the phone and make my business calls but
if i'm writing comedy the phone's
nowhere near me i don't want the
electricity even in my circuitry
i don't want to hear the phone buzzing
i know my schedule already it's not like
i'm going to get a late audition
and i look at it every hour or so
you know
well yeah well the phone is a [ __ ]
big distraction huge ari sofia was
absolutely correct
and i listened to what i already said
you know i have an iphone do i use
everything on that [ __ ] iphone not
even
a tenth or what time i don't even have
facebook on my [ __ ] iphone
none of that [ __ ] on my iphone
i got my hotmail
and i got my [ __ ] phone on there
that's it and i got pictures in the
camera which i take of the cats and my
daughter i don't take pictures of nobody
i don't do none of that [ __ ] it's menus
like chinese good food or spare ribs or
something i'll take a picture i don't
take pictures of that i don't use that
[ __ ] phone to its full capacity
so i'm thinking when i go in there too i
might as well just get a regular one
whatever the [ __ ] i'll listen to
podcasts on this
sometimes i listen to music on this
sometimes but yeah i don't listen to
music on my [ __ ] cell phone you know
your people played downtown last night
right yeah i saw that yeah they played
in the hall see but i don't really like
that one and i love them they put in
hollywood it's
the club scene in hollywood is weird i
just
i've never
i've never really enjoyed it so
going to see them there i don't really i
i saw them where gabriel's gonna be the
night before new year's the microsoft i
like that place
but
uh yeah that's pretty cool
so tonight
ah tonight i was getting ready to leave
the house
my wife had cooked i'd taken a nap the
baby was
we're building something for and my
phone rang
and uh i had it in my pocket like i said
i was getting ready to leave it was six
o'clock california time
and i got a weird [ __ ] call i got a
call that rattled me so much i i went
out in my car and i cried for 10 minutes
because i tell you guys and i tell my
wife
i think i tell my wife three times a day
how lucky we are you know and now the
luck that people have
that you don't really know it because
sometimes
even when something bad happens it's
kind of lucky
because something good happens from it
and it's hard to tell you that now
but throughout my life and other
people's lives i've seen little pieces
of mishaps that they've had
and they're kind of good when i was
growing up
right a couple months before my mom died
i became friends with this kid named
renee
his street name was called dede
and dee was a a big kid
big
and he had just fought
charlie gizzy and his brother and beat
him up
and he was 14 years old
he was that he was having beef
with a friend of mine a really dear
friend of mine at the time
my friend villainized him
and i meet this kid and i hit it off in
fact i really liked this dd kid and we
start hanging out
and pop goes the weasel my [ __ ] mom
died dede comes for the funeral and
dede wants to be a
pallbearer you know he introduces me to
his brother
his brother's name is carlos
so
when my mom died
it's so weird i moved with this kid john
but he was at war with dede but i hung
out with dede
me dede avillo glen conte lubes a bunch
of us hung out
behind uh avilo's house that he had that
shed that i always tell you guys about
where he painted the walls and had no
heat and we'd go back there in the dead
of the winter and drink and smoke dope
and
take acid and whatnot and
he was just part of the family deity and
one night
he said to me you want to come over and
eat and i went over there and i ate with
him and his mom and his grandma
but when i went over there
i noticed that his brother was a darling
his brother was a tough kid a darling
his mom lived there
and his aunt
but the ant
had a mental health issue
like she just lived in a room
i would always say hello to her she
would let me in but she didn't work she
didn't do nothing the mom worked
and indeedy went to school and carlos
did whatever he did
it was funny all those years when i was
16 and 17
on friday nights me and dede would get
together we'd eat like a [ __ ]
quaalude
we we were nuts you know i mean we were
[ __ ] nuts as kids
he was the guy that i was robbing
putting him feel with
he's the first guy i ever did an eight
ball with and stayed up all night
listening to [ __ ] rappers delight
i mean me and dee did a thousand crazy
things we got beat up one night by
hudson county park and his brother came
and beat the [ __ ] out of the guys an
hour later with six other [ __ ] tough
guys we just had a lot of adventures
growing up you know but i never forgot
his end
and i don't know what happened between
me and dede
you know you grow up uh
i live i moved uptown and i didn't see
dede as much and we just stopped being
friends but
we were tight and i
loved didi like i really loved i just
don't know what happened
somewhere along the line we lost
communication
i moved to colorado blah blah blah i
come back in 94
and i'm asking about dede and nobody has
seen him and then a couple years later
i get the most disturbing [ __ ] report
you know here's this
dede just wasn't a kid he was a
good-looking [ __ ] kid who ended up
becoming a good looking man his brother
is a good-looking [ __ ] man i mean
dede not only was a [ __ ] good-looking
dude but he played football he was
gigantic
he had a body like a [ __ ] adonis you
know and
he was just a [ __ ] great kid you know
and i lost contact with him and one day
i found out
that if you went to hudson county park i
parked by my house and drove around in
your car that within five minutes dede
would pull up on the driver's side with
no shirt on it and asked you if you
wanted a party
somewhere along the line mental health
had grabbed them
and he had started uh doing tricks
turning tricks with men
at a park this is mind-boggling to
when they told me this this is like
[ __ ] somebody telling you john wayne
is sucking dick at the park
you know and then i heard another
disturbing report that he had hiv
so
you know me dog i don't even know where
to start looking i got i got my own
[ __ ] problems
and in 2007
the weekend i quit doing coke
i did a friday night show
in north bergen for the high school and
i did a saturday night show in hoboken
for the police department
and when i get off stage who's in the
back [ __ ] dede
i give him a big hug and he
we call his brother and he tells me his
brother's married with two kids and blah
blah blah and
it just re-communicated me with those
guys who were such a part of my
childhood
i mean i i
carlos was a carlos was that kid that
drove me and dede to places you know
like when you you have a friend that go
you go to the movies your mom drives you
we didn't have a mom call those drovers
so we had to [ __ ] date carlos or
drivers i'm gonna tell you how cool
carlos was
there was one night i had a date carlos
just gave me his [ __ ] call
like carlos was my big brother man so
when i reconnected with dede he turned
me back onto carlos and the funniest
story was i was on the run people were
looking for me at 85. i was living in
bergen county new jersey
and i hooked up with this girl we went
food shopping somewhere but even deeper
into new jersey and at the supermarket
as he called us
and when i go carlos he looks at me he
goes hey you didn't see me i go what
they're looking for you too and he goes
yeah they're looking for you too
somebody told me that and that was the
last time i saw him in 1985.
so it's 2008 2007 i reconnect with
carlos now we're talking on a constant
every time i go home
the first [ __ ] night carlos picks me
up we smoke a number we go eat cuban
food or chinese food and he takes me
back to the hotel i give him a big hug
and that's what we do so
the last two times i went back i went
back with my wife last december
i didn't see carlos that was the first
time and then this year september
i was supposed to hook up with him and
dede
and i never heard from carlos and i was
kind of heartbroken
you know people have lives
whatever it would have been nice to go
eat a meal with dede and carlos and just
catch up
but i didn't hear from
and i didn't know what had happened and
i called him a few weeks after that i
never heard back from so
i just thought it was one of those
things in life when friends move on
as i'm leaving the house today the phone
rings [ __ ] call us
and we start talking he goes this is the
reason why i haven't called you because
i told you my son's been having problems
mental health runs in his family
so his son's been having a couple
problems with it you know
and they finally got a medication and he
felt great but at the same time dede
found out
that his nephew was having these
problems
and he thought it was because of his
mental health problems
so he slit his neck
[Music]
from one side of the throat to the other
he slipped both wrists
and both ankles
he decided to take 30 volumes
and he passed out and went to sleep
i guess the valium slowed down his
bleeding so he didn't [ __ ] die in his
sleep
so he got up
after two days of sleep and he was
covered in blood
at this point he realizes he's not dead
so he fills up the bathtub
and he's gonna electrocute himself
and he [ __ ] throws something in there
and it threw off the gfi receptacle
and the superintendent of something came
up and found them with the blood and
called the hospital and he's alive today
this was one of my best friends growing
up you know
that i loved with all my heart
and this is why i tell my wife
that
i'm very lucky every [ __ ] day when i
wake up
because
when i tell you about all those acid
trips and [ __ ] remember when i tell you
i did acid every day and you're like no
yeah it was dede i was doing the answer
with oh boy when i was doing those
[ __ ] gorilla pills
those [ __ ] powders
that thc crystal it was dede i was doing
it with
when i first started my first dissension
into cocaine for the first year it was
dede i was doing it with
me and dede did the [ __ ] you know
what i'm saying i'm not saying the drugs
gave them mental health i'm not saying
this [ __ ]
but what i'm saying is that he was fine
when we were kids
he was fine
his issues came up later on and i pray
for him you know before i left the
little candle for him
i mean he was one of my best friends
growing up i loved him with all my heart
i mean you know
and uh
this is life this is why
i can't even get caught up with stand up
or hollywood
or movies or tv i really don't give a
[ __ ]
because i'm so lucky to be in the
position i'm in right now
as just a human being
it's tough to explain that to people
it's very tough for me to explain that
to people but i really don't give a [ __ ]
about the special or i really don't give
a [ __ ] about comedy
or the podcast i cannot believe
that i got this second chance at life
and it makes me so [ __ ] happy at
times at the same time it makes me sad
you know why are you sad
you know i got two or three front like i
said you know i got like two or three
[ __ ] friends i grew up with the drugs
ate them up and spit them up and they're
walking around and they're alive
but
i don't know i don't [ __ ] know
well i mean you were saying that the uh
the drugs didn't give him the mental
health issues that's probably accurate
but
the drugs probably aren't great for
someone with those issues like that's
probably like that i'm not saying that
did it but
and it's
i'm so good that your friend's okay but
like what do you
it's scary when you hear stuff like that
to just think people get that low
and i have experience with friends and
people close to me but it's uh
nah this just drew me for a loop because
listen nobody has a [ __ ] crystal ball
and nobody could predict
i mean we can't predict our own future
never mind one of your best friend's
futures
but if you came to me and said this kid
was going to slit his [ __ ] throat
from ear to ear
and then cut his ankles and cut his
wrist 20 years ago i would have [ __ ]
punched you in the head just for putting
that kiss of death on a good friend of
mine you know
now it comes to life and it just uh
just makes me realize how fortunate i am
that's it and why
i don't
you know
why i don't give a [ __ ] about any of
this stuff
like i'm really happy about my daughter
i'm not even mad about jackie not
talking to me anymore i'm not even mad
about that anymore i haven't been that
mad at my ex-wife in months i giggle and
[ __ ] around with it but i don't really
give a [ __ ] no well there's nothing i
could do to change
i have no power over it this is
something
we really don't know when i'm young
you really don't know these things that
we this is powerless type [ __ ]
all you could control is what's in front
of you and what's in your realm
you know
when we're young i couldn't understand
this type of [ __ ] right now
because you obsess about the stuff that
you can't control yeah you obsess about
all this stuff when we're young that
you're like okay i'm gonna stop
obsessing now and go to sleep at night
you can't [ __ ] live unless you're
obsessed with obsessing yourself with
[ __ ] nightmares of your life and what
am i gonna do when my job is over in
three years who gives a [ __ ] we'll worry
about in three years you know like all
that type of [ __ ]
and that's and that's going back don't a
lot of people
when we were speaking or talking about
earlier about how we let our weight go
when we're focusing on work
don't a lot of people find like like
when you focus on like losing weight or
getting back in shape your other parts
of your life kind of get back in the
track
well
when you work on yourself lee
it's [ __ ] tremendous
it is tremendous because you pour more
into the other parts listen when you're
cheating yourself somewhere you're
cutting yourself short in other avenues
of your life
if you're cheating on your wife
if you're [ __ ]
gambling your family's money like me i
was snorting my family's money when me
and terry were just dating i was
snorting our extra money i was snorting
it affects the other parts of your life
it affected my stand-up it affected my
health
it affected my self-esteem
it affects everything the same when you
destroy yourself it affects everything
that same [ __ ] nickel when you look
out for yourself
it helps you in different areas
is it uh when you were walking out of
that kettlebell class on friday and you
went all three days right how good did
you really feel in your heart i loved it
yeah you felt like you had really
accomplished something
what did it make you do go home smile
take a shower
it made you come here you were a little
happier you did what you had to do
for the week at
whatever cost
that is
the goal
to get up on sunday
and go you know what this
week i'm gonna do uh i'm gonna go to the
gym three times on sunday morning you
say this to yourself
just three times
and you walk out of the third time
you know this week i'm gonna write three
paragraphs in my book these are why you
start with these little goals because it
empowers
the rest of your life my old goal for
monday wednesdays and fridays when i'm
in town
is to go to jiu jitsu
me getting beat up me getting choked up
that's just part of the game but when i
walk out of there as long as i go in
there and this could be anything
it doesn't have to be jiu jitsu it's an
hour that i'm taking care of myself
it could be going to the gym it could be
going to a pilates class it could be
going to a ceramic class
anything where you're taking care of
yourself
is beneficial it's beneficial and it's
going to help every area of your life
i don't give a [ __ ] if you go to the gym
and walk on the treadmill for 10 minutes
and sit for the next 50 minutes
i wouldn't give a [ __ ]
but if you did that three times a week
by the fourth week you're gonna go to
yourself why do i do this let me just
walk 20 minutes
that's why i tell people show up
don't worry about anything else just
show up
eventually you'll catch up just go down
there
go down there
i know it's not it doesn't really line
up because you've been doing comedy much
longer than you've been doing 2j2 but
you're blue getting your blue belt and
your special are pretty close like does
it have any correlation or is it
all listen man
getting the blue belt
i didn't deserve the blue belt
i see blue belts in there that'll throw
me up in the end wrap me up
he gave me the blue belt because i'm a
hard worker
i had goals he saw it
he saw it he would send me you're here
at night i got to come three times
doesn't matter
come hell high water i gotta come here
three times
you have
24 hours a day times seven
i'm talking about three hours of that
you know nobody's that busy
right yeah nobody's that busy
nobody's that busy because even if you
work monday through friday and you said
to me joey guess what
i'm going to do 10 push-ups and 10
sit-ups and 10 squats on saturdays and
sundays and then on wednesdays when i
get home from work i'm going to do that
you just helped yourself by doing those
30 [ __ ] movements
and then you say to me you know what
else i'm gonna do joey i'm gonna get a
[ __ ] notebook every morning
and before i
when i come out of the shower i'm gonna
write a page
of how i'm feeling
what my plans are for the day who i'm
mad at
who i'm mad at what am i mad about
you everybody goes to bed so mad you
wake up in the middle of night you're
mad you can't [ __ ] sleep you want to
go to sleep open up a page and write it
out within an hour you'll be sleeping
like a [ __ ] baby what do you do you
wrote a letter because it's your psyche
that's [ __ ]
not a letter just write about the
situation
write the whole situation down
two weeks ago i gave 200 to go gamble
and he came back with no [ __ ] money
and a frown you know what i'm saying he
don't even give me a [ __ ] losing
ticket here nothing
anything anything is better than you
sitting there
because sometimes while you're writing
it right like let's say you're mad at
your insurance rate went up oh my god i
am i'm pissed okay let's say you're mad
at your insurance rate whatever you're
writing about the situation
something else is going to come out of
that pen
that's the cure of insomnia writing
whenever i got insomnia but but listen
did i [ __ ] know that 28 no that i
know that 35 no i was too busy starting
coke i just realized this three four
years ago wait what do you mean the cure
from insomnia because i would think if
you start riding and you get on a roll
you'd get like you you your brain would
start going no you're getting that [ __ ]
out and you're gonna go right back to
bed
uh if you have insomnia it's just a bump
in the road it's just a bump in the road
you're missing your mom maybe an uncle
died maybe your favorite cousin get up
and write about them for 10 minutes
watch what happens
watch what happens
sometimes i just write for 30 minutes
then i go in the living room and i catch
10 minutes of law and order and i'm done
i got to go right to bed whatever's on
at 3 30 quarter to four i'm done
but i don't fight it no more i get up
with it now and i ride the energy wave
i write whatever bothered me because the
reason why i'm not sleeping is because
that's on my mind
that's smart i would think i didn't know
dog i didn't write this i didn't invent
this i think i read it in some [ __ ]
book and then i tried it i didn't invent
this i just [ __ ] tried with i read
and it worked for me
in fact i think i'm going to read that
book against the the
the war of art the art of war no the war
of war okay
the art of wars by shinsu okay the art
of wars by a pressler stephen pressfield
or something
i think he and then that book it's
either that or the one by uh
the horror stephen king the one that he
wrote
it talks about some nights just getting
up in the middle of night and
[ __ ] riding if you can't sleep or
some [ __ ] like that
okay that's good i'll try it because i
can never sleep but that's it man that's
it's so weird how my life changed when i
started making
taking little turns to taking care of
myself
just little things not nothing
outrageous no more soda no more soda you
know
a lot more water more whatever just
little things constant efforts you know
what i'm gonna go to bed you know you
you've been watching tv and say this to
yourself this is you gotta say to
yourself
okay last night i was watching uh
i took a big nap yesterday afternoon
like a three hour net oh [ __ ] and the
night before so i knew last night was
gonna be a late night
you left at 11 30 quarter 12
right okay and i had cuban coffee
so my wife went to sleep i stayed awake
and the next thing you [ __ ] know i
watched something on julius irving
and uh marvin bad news barnes about the
aba
and then i got caught up
in some [ __ ] movie
i'm watching this movie about 20
minutes and i was watching it
what [ __ ] movie was it jesus christ
that's how strong that was last night
the last two nights i've been so high at
the house by myself the first night
burke chrysler called me he goes hey
you're going to come over tomorrow i got
to call him back the next day i go bert
you call last night
we talking he's like yeah don't you
remember i told you to come over at five
o'clock tomorrow i didn't even [ __ ]
remember
that's how [ __ ] chiseled i was what
do you have
what what edibles did you have
everything
i had the transmission fluid
i had a couple stars
i had some of larry's happy pills i was
off and running jack
there was no drama in my life it was
late i was staying home
this is my last weekend at home you know
next week i do new years with joe
saturday night friday afternoon i do
kaluca casino
friday after that i'm in cleveland and
the friday after that i'm in
[ __ ] tempe arizona so
these next four weeks i'm working on the
weekend so i figured this last week at
home i'm going deep right in my living
room and [ __ ]
i love going deep in my living room it
was fun getting a little stoned in vegas
i like i liked gambling it was uh
it was pretty cool
like
you were able to come calm yourself down
because that's the biggest thing and i i
really think it relates to
with gambling like when you start going
too fast or you start betting too much
is when you start losing so that like i
i was thinking about you the whole time
because that's
i i did great that night because i was i
was on stars and i just was betting my
normal 15 i just got one on a run
and it was a
it's pretty crazy i don't know much
about gambling in that aspect i'm not a
card player
but i know that to win at
uh the slot machines yeah you got to sit
there for a [ __ ] hour or two oh and
that's or three or four
it's about patience
and nailing it nailing it no one went to
bed three quarters knowing when to bet
one quarter
no one won the bet three quarters
knowing when to bet one quarter no one
you know and then just catch it pretty
soon you start catching the machine and
you start flowing you hit two wheel of
fortune
you win 40 bucks and now and that's the
guy that wins
you know that's what i know about that
right my biggest issue
is leaving because i
like i lost but then i went and hit uh
like 150 off of a 20 on slot on slots
and i i gambled it away i kept trying i
kept trying to play that's why they call
it gamblingly
if you wanted to [ __ ] hold on to it
you just go up to your room and create a
museum just look at your six twenty
dollar bills and sit there all night
like a bumpy but you're in vegas your
natural
uh
whatever
instinct is to go back downstairs and
try to rock the house or say you know
what i'm gonna put 60 in my pocket
and i'm gonna bet with 60 and see what
happens
but i understood larry's logic larry
didn't want you to go to one of the big
casinos because he didn't want you to
lose your money at his casino there was
a five dollar table that you could milk
for two [ __ ] houses i went to the his
casino that's where i lost the rest of
my my winnings
it was the coolest night for me
because i
i just got lucky i
i thought first i
i had lot lost all week and joey gave
you gave me a hundred bucks to gamble i
was like this is joey's money and then
out of like this out of the the abyss i
saw it's not for dairy queen excalibur
has a dairy queen they didn't it wasn't
open but i was just thinking like what
would you do and there was this cool but
there was this cool black dude dealer i
went down along with him i used it on
gamble alone
and he just started we just started
going
and i ended up hitting like eight
blackjacks in like 30 minutes i
i just hit a ton of them i'm betting 15
bucks
and they just started giving me green
chips which is 25.
and i never bet those that like that
scares me
and when i got i i just i turned out i
turned your 100 into six
i was so happy
and i just got up and moved to the next
table
i just moved to the next table and they
said this is a 25 table i said okay
i'll try it with a hundred
if i lose that
i'll be done
and i just start winning winning when i
got up to like i
got up to right up to a thousand i think
pretty close
but i and i
anyways yeah i just got you you always
go on little runs but i sat there was a
professional blackjack player there but
in like a thousand a hand it was
freaking me out it was the coolest thing
i've ever seen
he got black he like he got black jacks
on like five hundred dollar chips
so you were up at g note leroux
well yeah i was pretty close to him did
you go to your room at the with the g
now no then where'd you lose the g note
okay so i got i was
i was down to like 700
because you just you what gets you is
the doubling because that that's it's
the [ __ ] up thing
there's hands that you're always
supposed to double which is doubling
your bet
and you double two or three of them and
then the dealer pulls the 21 out of
nowhere and it's
that's why it's a gambling and that's
why the casinos are here right so what
did you go back with your room when
after that five well well then see this
is where they get you i should have if i
had left one the tram that's why they
don't have clocks if they if i left when
the tram was still running i would have
been up like 700 bucks
but then i had to walk home and i'm i'm
gonna just
test out the other casinos so i lost a
couple
in uh
in the luxor with like you know the uh
that lady at the at the ice house the
nice lady who was the uh post post yeah
like the asian version of her
next to a guy in a wheelchair
and why whoa whoa whoa whoa you gamble
next to a guy in a wheelchair yeah
that's the kiss of death right there oh
why because
because
see this is why
no no asians
no [ __ ]
you know none of that stuff you gotta
you gotta be around by yourself that's
when you were winning see that's where
you [ __ ] up
i'm not saying not to be next to
wheelchair people i'm saying that you
had just one [ __ ] ten thousand
dollars you should have gone back to a
table by yourself
uh or you should just stay with the
black dude when the black dude left the
but actually the one who gave me the
most was an asian lady who and i love it
that i know we have a lot of asian
listeners but just you guys are too good
at being
dealers you go too fast the asian the
asian women are like ninjas they just go
like it's just it's the fastest thing
and you end up losing really fast
because they don't stop
because they've been they're just
amazing at their jobs and
so how much did you get back to the room
with i well then i went and gambled with
a guy from new york
and like so i got back with 400 all
right
and then the next day
i went to uh lunch with larry and his
son who was awesome but uh
i lost like 300 in like 20 minutes it
was the worst
it was the worst and you drove home and
that was it mama was waiting for you she
smacked you around a little bit
yeah well yeah but i mean
i i only go with what i can lose so i'm
like nothing
i'm still going to be able to pay my
rent
i mean i told paula what i lost she's
like you have a problem i was like okay
but uh
i don't know i just love it listen man i
think everybody has a different way of
burning energy it's not like you're
[ __ ] chasing bets every week no and
that's the problem
you went to vegas this is what you'll
enjoy to be honest with you this is what
you enjoy you enjoy eating
and you enjoy [ __ ] gambling oh yeah
where's tony bennett [ __ ] what the
[ __ ] this is why you gotta tell him you
enjoy gambling and eating i enjoy it by
myself
[ __ ] christmas and here we are
[ __ ] beautiful 2016's almost gone
2017 is right around the corner
it's time for another star
oh my god what the [ __ ]
you can't walk on one leg you know what
i'm saying right now the three wise men
were showing up with an envelope
they just started their journey
i can't walk at all right now oh [ __ ] it
you don't need to walk
who gives a [ __ ] you got nowhere to go
and nobody to see
ventura was great last weekend for
anybody who came out
to the hong kong end it was [ __ ]
tremendous
my set was a little off i went a little
long
but uh i love you guys i love that place
i like the guy who runs it the mushu
pork wasn't bad
and uh thank you i want to thank my main
man [ __ ] ryan
for coming out and giving me 20 bags of
[ __ ] reefer out there
we got mushrooms for you lee coming we
got another guy who promised mushrooms
for lee it was a great night if you came
out thank you very much man that's all i
want to [ __ ] say while lee was in
vegas eating and having a good time i
was up there hand to hand
combating it
with you [ __ ] you know i'm
saying up in ventura so it was great it
was raining here
it was uh three or four days of [ __ ]
torture here with the rain these people
cannot drive in the rain so it's pretty
interesting to see
me actually yes sir if you had to think
about it on my way to ventura the
weirdest thing happened
uh i've been playing phone tag for like
the last three weeks with with mike
roebuck
mike robot called him with the book of
knives oh absolutely it was hard just to
get a hold of him he's been working and
we're just having a conversation about
like uh
having really bad christmases you know
that his brother had
gone through some stuff and we hung up
and
i started thinking about [ __ ]
like what were my worst christmases do
you have any bad christmases growing up
growing up i had a bunch of i feel tired
i had always had great christmases
i uh as i got older my parents
would fight during the holidays a little
bit which
isn't great but every family does that
it's not like that's weird
but
my worst ones were i guess would
probably be out here the first few years
just
when i didn't really have anybody with
it usually i got pretty lucky to be
honest with you at least once somebody
or or work would have
a potluck or something that's
that's the great thing about people now
is they they usually tend to invite some
to something
maybe not on christmas day like that
would suck sometimes
but to at least be included in it
you know i meant to call dean delray
today
to invite him over i just didn't know my
schedule was gonna be like i said i was
tired
i got up at [ __ ] ten to six i went to
bed at what 1 30.
i got up at 10 to 6 expecting to get up
and i have to build the bike
i have to wrap a few things
i get up i go into the office
and everything's missing
like what the [ __ ] happened i go into
the living room my wife got up at three
and wrapped some [ __ ] and
so i woke up i go we're gonna build the
bike she goes now let's just build up
with her together
so i was already up so i got up at six
they both stayed in bed till eight
she said your daughter stayed in bed
till eight months this morning yeah i
wrote
i smoked some reef i made a protein
shake i just entertained myself
i've been really working on this book
lately
like i really now have the time
so i got the chapters
you know i'm working at two chapters at
once
and i've been trying to hit one chapter
at night and one chapter in the daytime
early and it's just uh
you know you put in two or three
paragraphs
the next day you look at it you put the
[ __ ] periods
maybe you take out three sentences that
are necessary and you start writing
three more paragraphs
so i've been on a pretty good pattern
you know
it's tough to write in those hotel rooms
it's tough to write three days and come
back to it
but this has been pretty good so i've
been sticking to that lately you know
it's
i you know i was thinking about add
today
i was last night we ended up going to
bert's house there was probably 10 kids
over there
12 kids over there none of them mercy's
age you know
all of them three or four years older
than mercy
so mercy's in heaven
a four-year-old around eight-year-olds
they're in their [ __ ] heaven you know
and uh
when i walked in with her she sat right
next to bert's daughter georgia she
really likes the older one and georgia
likes her
so they were together for a little while
and then next thing you know she's in
the [ __ ] yard on the swing
then she's putting on her jacket and
she's going in
and then she sits down on the couch and
then she gets up and they got that movie
on my wall and
whatever they got that on but no mercy
sits down and she gets up i unzip the
jacket for her she sits down again i
walk out of the room i see mercy going
to the doll room
and i'm sitting there and i'm thinking
about this [ __ ] thing that somebody
was telling me once
i was at a lunch and somebody was
blowing smoke up my ass about that kid's
a.d.d and i'm sitting there thinking to
myself
what the [ __ ] is this guy talking about
he's gonna be on medication that if not
he he loses his [ __ ] and i'm like what i
got it i've always had it you know
but i didn't realize i had it till
[ __ ] last night
when i was watching mercy [ __ ]
walking around
because when i was a kid they used to
always tell me this [ __ ] can't
sit still
i could never sit still as a child
that's why i didn't [ __ ] sleep and
stuff
shows you going from thing to thing the
thing to think like today she was on the
bike for 10 minutes then the bike was
over and then we played baseball for 10
minutes then we kicked the ball for 10
minutes
and then we [ __ ] played with bubbles
for 10 minutes and then we bent back in
and she sang to me tommy easter sent her
a microphone
with some [ __ ] box uh
princess whatever the hell it is so she
loves that thing and i knew she would
when tommy used to told me when he got
her i go jesus [ __ ] tommy easter
she's gonna love that thing a microphone
with a little miss
are you kidding me in the karaokes
oh my god oh yeah so the karaoke's with
the song
you're following me she knows she likes
miss sophia yeah princess is so freaky i
mean i don't know nothing there's like
10 of them she listens to you know but
she was on that and then she was in the
[ __ ] thing with the hot wheels it
never ends
so i was thinking about if you really
have this do you really have to treat it
because my generation nobody treated
nothing they just gave you more soda
until you [ __ ] went crazy you know
add do you know anything about this i
don't i mean but i don't i don't know if
it's a is it considered
four years old and four isn't that just
being a a kid a kid yeah that's how i
look at it it's just being a kid listen
man she don't
think
she's got nine best friends at daycare
yeah but you know what she's happiest
when she's by herself
she's an only child like i was so
she's hugging kids at daycare she hangs
out with a little black dude who fell
down and bumped his head the other day
oh [ __ ] and they put a bandage on his
head hysterical
so my wife walked in he kept
pointing to the bandage
yeah because they put helmets on when
they ride bicycles
i would hope so but the [ __ ] ledge
caught him right under the helmet the
poor kid
it's not bad enough he's already deaf
and you know he's the cutest little
[ __ ] [ __ ] black kid you ever
seen in your life every time i see him i
knuckle him high five and give him a hug
he gives me a hug i've known the kid for
two years i was swimming with the kid
when he was a baby me him and my
daughter
so i know zave since he was a [ __ ]
baby so
that's hysterical
but yeah she wants did she have a good
time well yeah i mean i don't think you
have anything to worry about
she had a great time at crisis last
night i'm very happy i want to really
thank him for inviting me over there it
was very nice to him
he knows that you know we were going to
go to george's house and george just has
little dogs and [ __ ] and
it's adults you know every time we go to
georgia we have a great time but she's
the star of the night because she's the
only [ __ ] kid
right all adults and they play with her
and stuff you know
but to be around kids
and she got to look at them and stuff it
was really great for she was dead till
nine you know we kept her out late last
night partying so i knew she was gonna
sleep late today
i was gonna sleep until she didn't
really get the concept of waking up
for christmas when we showed her that
santa ate the cookie
she looked at us like it was a magic
trick like
you know saying like she didn't really
she got it but she didn't give a [ __ ]
she was just ripping through those toys
ripping through the papers and [ __ ]
she's like yeah i don't care how they
got here yeah i don't [ __ ] know she
you know my wife put the gifts up
unbeknownst to me what i wanted to do
she goes no let's put him out i had a
whole plan
that there's nothing there in the
morning and awesome there's a thousand
gifts there there's nothing there at
night
and all sudden you wake up there's a
thousand [ __ ]
gifts gone i wanted to put the dish with
the milk
and then spill it and then as soon as i
heard the door i'd be hey come back you
just missed santa claus yeah yeah
[ __ ] my wife didn't want to do that
i you know i
who the [ __ ] knows so i didn't know when
she put the gifts out i said this is it
this is it i didn't like it
it took the [ __ ] it took the
the pizzazz off because it's supposed to
be like this yeah it's supposed to be
christmas morning
that's what i felt i don't know yeah i
never i was always awesome for me i
for me i want to go to bed and there'd
be nothing there
just a tree with lights and i can't find
the [ __ ] presents i can't figure
where the [ __ ] they got them in
you know i know they're around here my
friend told me there's no [ __ ] santa
claus
but i know there is my mom and dad
wouldn't lie to me there you know
whatever the [ __ ]
and then all of a sudden you wake up
christmas morning and there's [ __ ]
toys everywhere
one of them is built that's christmas
you know
show him a picture
you know now you could [ __ ] buy the
videotape
of santa drinking milk or something in
your house and show your kid
that's the same you could download
there's something you could download now
i don't know i don't [ __ ] know i just
wanted to make it that way
if i think about my worst christmas i
gotta think about my best christmas that
my best christmas was a 205 west 88th
street when we left it mine as a family
there was no presents and we came back
at three in the morning they were
[ __ ] presents okay
that's a [ __ ] trick right there
that's my story and i'm sticking to it
[ __ ] let me give some shout outs
real quick here
and we'll get out of this i want to
first off i want to thank uh
i want to wish the whole church family a
happy merry christmas and a happy new
year you know i love you guys
again my man ryan from detroit
bobby sharon and crystal dennis mcgarry
paul lynch
bob lalingus and his family jj steemler
william avila michael trevino jimmy
dominguez noah's ark and the
[ __ ] ortegas and [ __ ]
making it happen up there
in [ __ ] northern california
and that's basically it my man you know
i wanted to do a podcast
i just
i uh
i had a lot of [ __ ] bad christmases
you know
but they weren't bad in the sense that
i brought them upon myself
okay
they weren't bad because life was cruel
to me
in many ways i brought it upon myself
the one christmas that i thought was
going to be bad was prison
and it was tremendous
like the next day the 26th i opened up
my eyes and that's it and that's how
some people view christmas
they view christmas like they just want
to wake up and it's the 26th of
september of december i'm sorry
and i understand that like you know it's
that hard of a day for you and i think
there was a time to like when my mom
first died those first couple years i
didn't really want to experience
christmas it wasn't going to be
christmas without it i thought it would
never be christmas without as a matter
of fact
um
if it wasn't for my daughter it'd just
be another day for me
i'm not going to lie to you like i told
you in the document three years ago
once you lose a parent you could move on
but it's like eating food but no salt on
it
you know what i'm saying that's how your
life becomes when you don't have a
parent you know that's why uh
those first couple years christmas
didn't mean dick
chrisman didn't mean dick til i got back
in like a family environment
like in 86 87
christmas meant something again because
i had a girlfriend and a family and i
had somewhere to go
but all those years i was out there
[ __ ] playing a scavenger i didn't
give a [ __ ] it's funny because today i
talked to timmy holloway
and we were talking about the
christmases we used to spend at his
house
you know christmas 81
christmas 82
and i think uh
christmas of 84 i went down there to eat
at this house they were tremendous
they're [ __ ] tremendous what ages are
that is that
17 18.
like 22 or something like that 21.
but the one when we were 17
you know we walked in there [ __ ] half
stone we ate like animals
it was a different time you know
it was a different time christmases
and uh we were talking this morning him
and i about how
how much life has changed you know
and in many ways some ways i can handle
it in some ways i can't
you know why not a lot of ways
i don't know sometimes it gets late at
night my wife goes to bed
i'm in the living room watching tv and i
start getting self doubts at night i
start thinking about like
more [ __ ] i could be doing you know here
i am [ __ ] around
i don't know i beat myself up just like
everybody else
but i also beat myself up at times about
uh how fast
this life went like one minute i was
somewhere and the next minute i was
somewhere else like some nights i
questioned myself like
where the [ __ ] did it go and how fast
did it go
when you're 20 you really don't see
you think you have all this time but you
really [ __ ] don't
it goes so goddamn quick
and
why does it like is it upsetting because
like you think you're like a fear of
death i'm no no no no no not at all at
times i'm i'm uh
at it at times it's kind of hard that
that's all behind me now that those
aspects of my life are behind me now
okay but all the bad aspects
i'm also sad about
the good aspects of my life back then
that are behind me now
you know when i go back to new jersey
that deli i grew up in is no longer
there no longer exist
all those people that i used to walk up
and down uh you know it's so funny right
now i'm writing about
1983 when i was a burglar in snowmass i
had a day job i was taking night classes
you know i never bought coke
all right i was only buying weed but if
i come to you i'd say listen my roommate
wants to buy some coke the coke was
really for me and what i was doing was
robbing coke dealers
but since i didn't snort coke they
didn't suspect me
are you with me okay yeah so they didn't
suspect me
so for about five or six months i was
driving drug dealers but nobody
suspected me because i didn't do coke
they would offer it to me and i go no i
don't do coke i smoked pot but meanwhile
you were doing a ton of coke i wasn't
doing a ton of coke i was robbing coke
and snorting little by little when i get
home at night i wasn't snorting in front
of nobody i was and i was doing it to
the tea
to the tea
i never broke my rule
i never did cocaine outside the house at
night
okay when i was at a bar i'd have one
drink and i'd run home and get high
but i never got high the whole time in
snowmass in the beginning out
so what i would be
how high are you right now lee oh well
it looks like you're going through
changes again this is changes right now
i can tell you're making funny faces you
go it's like somebody farted you're
covering your nose
so it was funny that i was doing great
i had them all fooled
but i had done a burglary
in september or labor day weekend
and i got away with it and it was right
in my backyard and i said [ __ ] it i'm
not gonna clip up in my backyard no more
i'll clip in aspen and i'll clip down
valley i only rob drug dealers and
snowmass i won't rob businesses
and then one christmas eve i went out
and drank a couple [ __ ] southern
comforts and orange juice and i got all
[ __ ] up and i kicked the door down in
like four places and the next day made
the papers
and people are paranoid and people were
talking about it like i would go to play
darts at people's houses and
smoke some pot with them and they were
all saying can you believe somebody
broke them all and then one night some
guy even said yeah they were robbing
some drug dealers and they were zeroing
in on the guy that was robbing the
cocktails they were zeroing into the guy
named todd something
i'll never forget this and the whole
time i'm hanging with these guys and
they're telling me it's that though todd
that's breaking into all the drug
dealers
little did they know it was me i was
gonna say are you tired no i wasn't
tired at all so i had it going really
good
i had money put away i had cold put away
i had to block a hash put away
put away your gold
yeah what does that mean because i click
gold from people
i had a bunch of [ __ ] put away
and my plan was just to sit on it
and if i needed to make a move
this was like money in the bank for me i
was making money as an electrician's
helper i wasn't paying much rent i was
eating salami and [ __ ] salads then
and a steak for dinner
i was buying weed and all the coke i was
snorting was for free because i was
robbing it and i would always get a
little cash and i would rob the drug
dealers
so i rob those four [ __ ] things
the pictures in the not my picture
they do a write-up in both papers
they don't mention drug dealers but when
i'm out one night they start talking
about these drug dealers that are
getting robbed i'm giggling the whole
time
because i know they don't have who gots
how harder than that make the newspaper
the because there were four businesses
well yeah the four businesses like yeah
but how did the drug dealers complaining
i didn't know but i had heard that one
night somebody said you know i heard
about businesses but i also heard drug
dealers are getting robbed oh my
so i'm sitting there getting terrible
for everybody
how long have you been there
i got there maybe july of 83. okay
and it's november of 84. oh i had
already terrorized like 10 drug dealers
and here's the beauty i would hit them
three times
like they would get hit three times like
the second time you figure [ __ ] i'm
gonna get out of the bed
wait wait but that was even a torture
chain but then
how long would he give them between
robbings
four or five weeks so i clip i love
refuel let them get back on their feet
and get confident and i'd see him out
talking
like yeah i got a gun now and [ __ ] okay
and i just wait for them to go skiing
and kick down their door yeah
every time they went skiing
boom
there i was
and i and i wasn't even kicking in that
door to be honest you know those drug
dealers got their doors kicked in i had
the [ __ ] key
oh i had i figured out how to break into
my friend jimmy god rest his soul made
another tool for me
that you know all the condos were the
same lee
it was called creekside so it was a the
[ __ ] k
they all had the same door four doors in
each condo
b
8k
d e f g h i j
k 11 [ __ ] buildings
are you kidding me or what
what letter did you get to okay i hit
the whole [ __ ] thing you know me i
don't really think i'm gonna stop but i
i got time for that [ __ ]
so
all right so
it's [ __ ] january 1st
in my [ __ ]
ketosis i'm sitting there
and i'm thinking to myself you know what
man
i'm gonna go back home
but i'm gonna rob this one last joint
all right there was this joint
that had a safe that was filled to the
gills
that wasn't stapled to the floor
plus the guy made mistake number one
the [ __ ] he had out in the glass
he would never put it in the safe he'd
leave it out all night in his own house
no this was a business
so
even though
wait wait someone is in business
i can't tell you what type of business
give your imagination i just gave you a
[ __ ] hit
so this guy first off i had hooked up
with a dude who was on the run from
minneapolis
i had hooked up with a dude
i had hooked up with two dudes that
changed my life at that age
i had hooked up to a dude that was
tremendous with weapons
but i
also
looked up what a
who was a [ __ ] stone cold criminal so
i thought i'll fill you in on this in
later chapters
so i [ __ ] thought
and he taught me how to
i would tell him i would in those days
you had to go get a box okay
this is when it was [ __ ] scary
because you were putting i was already
telling you
so i would have to get a box
of
camera
in those days if you wanted a camera
that came in a [ __ ] box this is how
much of an amateur i was
and i would take pictures of them all
and then by mistake i would click the
pictures of the alarm system
and i would bring them to my friend i
would get them developed
okay then bring them to my friend
tell them everything the measurements
i'd take
picture but i take pictures of the
building so the people at kodak wouldn't
suspect it because in those days you got
your film developed in one hour
but they looked at your pictures you
know what i'm saying right i never
wanted them to just see pictures of one
target so i took pictures of
a bunch of stuff
and i was always talking about
architecture so i didn't know if i was
an architecture student or whatever this
is a small town
so i'd have to go get the pictures and
bring them to him and he would tell me
he'd go there one day
and then he'd tell me how to break into
the alarms
where to cut the alarm system how much
time i had before the cops got the
[ __ ] back up this guy knew everything
so i said if i'm gonna go home
i already got an envelope to go home
with
i could go home for [ __ ] two weeks
and live like a king but why not really
live like a king let me rob this [ __ ]
last joint
so i planned to hit this joint like the
first week of january and i wasn't going
home till february 1st
it went i [ __ ] planned and guess what
else happened a [ __ ] blizzard of snow
so i'm talking about [ __ ] all these
east coast storms i'm talking about a
colorado storm
[ __ ] eight inches in three hours that
type of [ __ ] like it's a whiteout type
[ __ ]
so the night i planned it it's a [ __ ]
whiteout
so what happens so i leave from where i
live
maybe 300 yards on this mountain and i
creep up
to this little mini mall where this
business was at
and they had a front entrance and a back
entrance
my plan was to go through the front
entrance
uh
this is ten years before i met josh wolf
and clipped the safe pick up the safe
and throw it off the [ __ ] mountain
this was before the snow i was gonna let
the safe and gravity do its own work
what if it popped over and the money
went flying then i'd pick up the cash
and run like a [ __ ] and i
wouldn't have to take the safe back to
the garage and i wouldn't have to have
the evidence
so i cut the two wires there was no
[ __ ] cameras in those days
i cut the two wires
and to my [ __ ] behold
there was a whiteout
but the [ __ ] cops came up the hill
with their lights on
and two cop cars came up with their
lights on which gave me a
a jump
so i just ran home i didn't even i just
cut the wires and i must have cut the
wrong wire they got the [ __ ] call oh
jesus so they come up
i jump off the back balcony
and i run home
and let me tell you something it was
snowing so hard that yeah
that hole was filled within 10 [ __ ]
minutes
like it was filled that's how much snow
there was like i was falling everywhere
but it was snowing so much
and i went a long way i went all the way
to k
because i had shoveled
so i knew k and all that was open i
walked down the thing my mistake was i
took my boots off when i brought them in
they followed the snow path to my door
and then the cops like
where were you coming from and i said i
came from aspen and all this [ __ ] there
you go i must have not gotten mixed up
with the snow but i didn't ride no
jewelry snow but now they knew
now i was on a short list now you're on
their radar so now i had a boogie
you know so for three weeks i had to
walk around
wait to see if they were gonna pinch me
they never pinched me but now the the
burglaries also stopped
so i definitely knew it was me
do you think you had to command another
robbery
i did but there was nothing to rob that
interest me
at that point all my challenges have
been done
unless i wanted by this time i knew they
were on to me it's not like they were
watching me it was too small of a place
to be watched they could always uh
you know but they were at least watching
out for [ __ ] now now they knew
how many people
do you think are there
that just live
and around the country move every couple
years and just move city to the city and
rob
i thought you think so
it catches up with you
you leave
you know you're like a [ __ ]
slug you leave [ __ ] behind
so you leave enough [ __ ] behind they'll
come back to haunt you it did me
it didn't mean
it didn't work what they found out in
the different cities i was at didn't
[ __ ] help my cause
no i can't
you know when
when i went to get
for my preliminary hearing
when i fired my attorney that's when
they took me in the back and the dea was
there and they were showing me pictures
the district attorney from boulder
the guy that was trying to prosecute me
was giving me paperwork
and showing me he goes listen man
we did like a thorough background check
on you
you were [ __ ]
in trouble in san francisco
they just started spitting it out you
were in trouble in new york city
you were in trouble in jersey you got in
trouble in connecticut they [ __ ] did
a thorough
check all those places i thought i was
being [ __ ] cute at
they [ __ ] knew about especially aspen
and especially the story i'm telling you
right [ __ ] now
jesus
[ __ ] craziness man
what does that make you feel like when
you hear that
when i went they told me to my face yeah
oh i knew
i knew everything comes back to haunt
you don't think you get away with and
this is way before computers
what they had done was called you know
i'm saying like this is when you call
this was way before computers were
very you know
83 yeah they were still
some people had really good computer
systems
and some people didn't you know in 84 i
got busted for weed
and they already had that fingerprint
thing in the car
where if you don't have an id they put
your [ __ ] fingerprint or some [ __ ] in
there
you know i went to other towns where i
gave them a name
and it was a it was a felony i did but i
gave him a name it takes them 10 days to
run your [ __ ] name in some places not
anymore
not anymore jack it's immediate right
it's [ __ ] 10 seconds
10 seconds everything comes back on ncic
in the old days they had to send
fingerprints
and that gets put on the list
so you might get bailed the [ __ ] did you
electrocute yourself
did you no no what the [ __ ] just
happened i'm just really high so you
might you might get arrested on a friday
give him a fake [ __ ] name right when
i was
doing all that stupidity you might get
arrested on a friday gave him a fake
name bail out monday
and they wouldn't know for 30 [ __ ]
days
[ __ ] then they would catch you when you
came back to court
if you came back if you were that dumb
to come back
and people they come back you know who
came back
who me and that's how long
it took them
i went back did the community service
they didn't catch it was me till
a year later in seattle i got arrested
and i saw
that i wasn't wanted
but they figured out that was one of my
aliases
oh
so like yeah we did you did it but we
know you who you are now yeah so they
they just said [ __ ] it we're not gonna
arrest you we just know you [ __ ] did
that [ __ ]
it's pretty interesting now you can't do
that now the computer system they got
you in 10 [ __ ] seconds
so it's really do you think
can you have a career after you get out
of jail like if you were a thief
could you go to jail did the time get
out and just start doing again
as a thief
listen man i don't know anything about
today's world and what's going on
i do know that i see [ __ ] cameras for
everything
right yeah i do know now that when a
liquor store gets robbed
it comes on eyewitness news i know that
one
a burglary happens and it's an amateur
burglary
it's on film
you follow i'm saying to you if
four [ __ ] spanish kids throw a rock
through a glass and climb in and take
the things in the jewelry store that's
street [ __ ] they're going to show you
that
but they're not going to show you
footage of people who are in there
taking safes and
you know knowing people who know how to
[ __ ] chisel safes and i'm going to
show you those tapes no and and
regular ordinary homes have those
security systems now like my my uh
monkey yeah
i had four times before the cops get
there
if you don't give me what's in your home
safe
that's the real deal i could shoot you
from the head four [ __ ] times after
you press that buzzer and
walk out of there with luggage and [ __ ]
and the cops still won't be there
yeah
is that your line to them i could see
you in there four [ __ ] times don't
press that button
you shoot that you press that button i
shoot you four times in the head what
good are you you know saying
i can still get out of there by the time
you know
they realize you're [ __ ] out of it oh
that's a [ __ ] up thought to have to
have
i just got no up
huh i had to get in the lawn yeah
absolutely it's spooky over there it's
spooky
it's hooky spooky over there dog it's
[ __ ] spooky tonight it's [ __ ] dark
[ __ ] you too quiet yeah it's a bit too
quiet you got the yard and [ __ ] [ __ ] you
[ __ ] you rudy was telling me when he was
on the podcast yeah rudy give me the
guy's [ __ ] number [ __ ] you
give me the whole thing booby traps
lights explosives you missed the mexican
ice cream man
over here yeah yeah yeah i stopped
[ __ ] with him
when i got up to like 336 i was like i
can't be [ __ ] with the mexican ice
cream man no more [ __ ] shows up
at the way this time tonight i need him
like i need a [ __ ] milkshake at two
in the morning
[ __ ] him he had me off chiseled out for
a fat dude so he would sit in front of
my window and just ring his little ice
cream bell [ __ ] three four times a
day he even beat the horn like i'm stuck
when the ice cream man beeps the horn
you know you're a fat [ __ ] like like
you're i was walking i was going to the
gym that's when i first moved here too i
was walking my wife to work in the
morning and then i would stay walking
for an hour
and then i would go home
eat weight watches go to the gym and i
noticed damn i'm putting on [ __ ]
pounds there was that [ __ ] mexican
ice cream man beeping the horn at me
he used to lure me after they talk to
him they sell me a [ __ ] ice cream was
he mad like he was mad at you for making
him wait not at all he'd wait out there
till i got the beep
you know after 15 minutes you're like
there's got to be beeping for me i look
out the window he's out there waving
i'd [ __ ] say [ __ ] it he's out there
you want something no i'm going to get a
double cone
then i realize jesus christ these double
cones are [ __ ] killing me so i cut
that [ __ ] off then he switched
governments
he's like there's 10 different dudes now
every time one guy gets comfortable they
hear something and they [ __ ] leave
town so it's tough having an ice cream
and he works it listen if you sit here
at six o'clock at night
from six to 11 lee
he'll come by twice an hour
really yeah he comes right he just goes
all his routers
from chandler to the corner up all these
side creepy houses here that's what his
route is
he'll come by here at six
at about 6 42
and then about 7 15
then about ten to eight and he takes a
breather and he goes to about 11 11 30.
i'd be getting home from the comedy
store and i'd see his red lights by my
house
and i go damn this guy's a [ __ ] pimp
yeah they don't mess around that like
they're out tonight and yesterday after
they were out tonight yeah of course
yeah they don't give a [ __ ] christmas
eve
they're immigrants they don't give a
[ __ ] there's no christmas that their
family is stuck in whatever country
that's in there with them that's all
right yeah but you did you notice every
business around here was closed today oh
yeah of course nothing was open nothing
denny's and i'm not going to denny's
i know noho dinah they always open
and 7-eleven was open that's it the
denny's literally had a line out the
door well you want 11 30 you have to
[ __ ] church like
a moog dolores you got to go at nine to
church on sunday
because if not it's a horror show over
there once church gets out today was a
big church day brother you're not eating
breakfast in this town
they don't give a frenchman's [ __ ] it
was a tough day this town for breakfast
egg mcmuffin was delicious wait till you
look at your [ __ ] later on it's green
and stuff
the egg ain't even real
i have them
oh you'll see him oh yeah yeah yeah
i don't know
it's a great way to start the week i'm
happy you people [ __ ] spent it with
us the last hour and a half i know it
wasn't a big ho-hum type of [ __ ]
energy but it's just me and lee on
christmas eve
[ __ ] no christmas night yeah [ __ ]
[ __ ] to your people
uh we're not gonna do a podcast the rest
of the week we come back to you
[ __ ]
january 2nd or 3rd direct
we're gonna take a week off and hang out
and clean the office and
come back one night and do some [ __ ] in
here and that's it man
we just wanted to
spend some time with you guys and tell
you that we love you
we're not [ __ ] leaving you we're just
taking a few days off gives you a chance
to listen to all the old podcasts
and uh
do whatever it is you need to do but
i'm gonna make your transition [ __ ]
smoother okay
number one i want to present to you for
christmas because i know you guys got
some cash everybody's trying to change
their life you want to change your life
go to onit.com right now try the alpha
brain just for starters 100 money back
guarantee this is part of your
resolutions what do you got to [ __ ]
lose 100 money back guarantee go to
hunter.com right now and press in church
and get 10 off delivered to your house i
can't help you with the clubs and the
kettlebells i can only help you with the
supplements again any supplement in
there from shroom tech the alpha brain
to the uh the hem force protein i stand
behind 150 [ __ ] percent
go right there start with the alpha
brain go to uh
honor.com and press church boom
c-i-h-u-r-c-h that's how high i am
already tonight number two
leo cop to these people i love these
people i don't get them because i don't
[ __ ] like cooking i don't like
[ __ ] cooking i'm through with [ __ ]
cooking i don't even i like making
sandwiches i make tuna fish like a
[ __ ] i made some nachos the
other night because i was desperate my
wife had all the chemicals but you know
what
maybe one maybe one time i'll bring up
one of the blue aprons over
okay maybe i'll do that well i had like
three deliveries and i liked it the food
was great
against the food it's measured perfectly
it's exactly what you want and how you
want it it's portioned like a [ __ ]
normal human being you understand me
that's what the beauty is what were your
favorite meals dog oh my god what were
the ones so far that you've gotten that
were good i've had so many good ones
i've had i've had a bunch of great uh
burgers i've had a bunch of great pasta
dishes pasta pomodoro this week they
have a bunch of great dishes
they have spicy cabbage enchiladas this
week okay and and and that's the crazy
cool you get to learn how to make that
and they tell like tell you how to dice
a potato how to make garlic paste they
show they have videos for you
then they like because i do all that i'm
the how you go i'm the one who googles
and finds it but they have it right
there for you they have a seared chicken
and sauce and sage gravy
with carrots and mashed potatoes you
know how to make i learned they taught
me how to make mashed potatoes hold on
one second oh sorry this is all for less
than ten dollars per person per meal
blue apron delivers seasonal recipes
along with proportion ingredients to
make delicious home-cooked meals choose
from a variety of new recipes each week
or let blue apron's culinary team
surprise you recipes are not repeated
within a year so you'll never get bored
customize your recipes each week based
on your preferences blue apron has
several delivery options so you could
choose what fits your needs and there's
no weekly commitment so you can only get
deliveries when you want them each meal
will come with a step by step easy to
follow recipe card just what we was
talking about and again they're
proportionate ingredients and can be
prepared in 40 minutes or less all right
you get home from work you take a shower
and there it is blue apron's freshness
guarantee
promises that every ingredient in your
delivery arrives ready to cook or
they'll make it right
check out this week's menu what is it
lee
this week's menu is a spicy cabbage
enchilada with a yellow tim tomato sauce
they have a seared chicken and a sage
gravy with carrots and mashed potatoes
and they have a tuscan style roast pork
with kale and salsa verde all right
check out this week's menu and get your
first free meals free
i'm talking free with free shipping by
going to blueapron.com
slash church
c-h-u-r-c-h
you'll love how good it feels you'll
love how good it tastes and you'll love
how happy you get by creating incredible
home-cooked meals with blue apron so
don't wait do yourself a favor dog start
the year off right that's blueapron.com
church
c-h-u-r-c-h this is blue apron it's a
better way to cook i also wanted to
introduce these savages to the company
uh you're going to love them by now you
heard i don't know if you heard me
talking about the scores of cash you can
make by betting
my bookie.net
well it's bowl season if you haven't
check them out this is the perfect
weekend to get into action
you got the independent bowl the
military bowl the russell athletic bowl
the citrus bowl the peach bowl the
fiesta bowl listen if you're gonna make
some money you got the week off this is
the week to do it right now you have
plenty of times to watch the games and
scout the teams the boat games are here
so it's time to crush your pits
lay down some money and score big
join me and thousands on online players
and start betting at my bookie.net
my bookie is an industry-leading online
sports book the end of the year with a
bang
my bookie is offering 100 percent bonus
up to a thousand dollars when you
deposit before the end of the year and
its players enjoy the fastest payouts in
the business when they win i would only
recommend a service that's good to me
and my listeners and to others that's
why i urge you to make your way to
mybookie.net
you win they pay no hassles you're
wasting your time betting somewhere else
i know a lot of you guys gamble here's
the one you were waiting for don't sit
on the sidelines this ball season do me
a favor join now and my bookie will make
will match forget about me join now and
my bookie will match your first deposit
with a hundred percent bonus lee you
hear me that's right so if you join with
a hundred dollars you'll get a 200
bankroll to play with
use promo code joey j-o-e-y
to activate the offer or visit
mybookie.net today or call 844 900 bets
again 844
900 bets
play
win get paid [ __ ]
visit my bookie today or call 844 900
bets listen you're going to sit there
all week you might as well make a little
scratch
with some [ __ ] money so start betting
at mybookie.net
again i want to thank blue apron again i
want to thank annette
again i want to thank all the great
sponsors we've had this year from
tushies to meundies to to zip recruiter
but listen man i want to thank you guys
the most the church family and i want
you to sit down and uh this week
smoke a [ __ ] joint put on your
favorite deep purple album you and bobby
sharon
and uh write your goals down right what
you want for the new year i was i've
been writing them for the last week
what i want to make better how i'm going
to make it better i got to get my
nightlife cooking a little bit my
nightlife is a little [ __ ] boring i
got to mix it up a little bit i'm going
to have to catch a jiu jitsu at night
maybe switch a podcast to a morning we
might have to switch it up here
something's not working for uncle joey
so uh i got to make it right but listen
again i want to wish you a merry
christmas i want to wish you a happy
holiday i want to wish you a happy new
year
uh health
happiness and then the money comes later
trust me i'm telling you
lee my brother is so [ __ ] high right
now
he can't wait to get off air so he could
go get air or jump off a building or do
whatever it is he's gonna do again thank
you very much for being my family thank
you for supporting my specialist ceso
thank you for supporting myself and lee
and for being the best [ __ ] family
we've ever had all right
have a great [ __ ] rest of the holiday
and a happy new year and we'll catch you
guys next monday morning thank you for
listening have a great holiday stay safe
be careful i love you [ __ ] with
all my heart
[Music]
you